[Music]
Naya Rivera's former Glee co-star
Heather Morris wants to help in the
search of her missing friend
the actress shared on Twitter that she
wants to conduct an on foot
search-and-rescue mission I wish she'd
hold my hand Naya went missing on the
afternoon of July 8th after renting a
pontoon boat at Lake Piru her
four-year-old said Josie was discovered
sleeping on the boat that they had
rented hours earlier after the Ventura
County Sheriff's Office shared that they
were winding down their search for the
night the actress responded by writing I
understand your team is doing everything
in their power but we are feeling
helpless powerless and want to help in
any way I have left a message with a
department of rescue and air today and I
will call again tomorrow
Heather's messages come after nice
family visited Lake Perry with
investigators on Saturday a spokesperson
for the Ventura County Sheriff's Office
told eg on Saturday they've been
utilizing all the same resources for the
last three days which includes cadaver
dogs sonar technology and helicopters
they've also been getting assistance
from Tulare and San Luis Obispo
sheriff's office they said Naya is still
presumed dead and hope they can bring
closure to her family
[Music]
Heather is one of many of nice friends
and former co-stars who have expressed
their hope for her rescue the 33 year
old wrote on Instagram
hashtag bring Naya home back in 2017
Heather gushed over Naya and how they
always kept in touch after Glee - are
you still closest wit from the Gleek
yeah well I'm dyin I keep in touch a lot
yeah and you are you guys kind of
bonding over the mom thing now you have
that yeah yeah yeah we've taken our kids
to you know the real world Park and just
we like to keep in touch and just like
you know talk about things going on in
our life
you